قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه الى قوتها
اصابت نحو 70 جنديا روسيا ودمرت منظومه
مدفعيه خلال قصفها مواقع تمركز القوات
الروسيه في مقاطعه زبوجيا واضافت ان
طائرتها نفذت خلال الساعات الماضيه غارات
عده على مواقع تمركز القوه الروسيه
ومنظوماتها الصاروخيه
واسقطت تسعه طائره مسيره كما قصفت نقطتي
تحكم ومستودعيني لتخيره
الجيشيه شنت خلال ساعات الماضيه 75 هجوما
على اهداف المدنيه وبنيه تحثيه في مقاطعه
عده لا سيما في خير شرقه
شلت القوات الروسيه خلال الساعات الماضيه
10 غارات جويه استهدفت البنيه التحتيه
المدنيه في منطقه دونيتس كما اطلق العدو
65 صاروخا على مدينه خيرسون نتجت عنها
اضرار في منشات مدنيه واصابات بين
المدنيين وصدت وحدات من قوات الدفاع
الاوكرانيه هجمات المحتلين باتجاه اند
ريفكا في منطقه لوجان وهجمات باتجاه هيام
بوليفيا
وفوديان ومارينكا في منطقه دنياك